- Hello, have y'all ever met before?
- We have not.
- No.
- Um, yeah no.
- [Kelly] Oh, go ahead
with the accent, okay?
It's so cute!
- Yo, do you know what's really funny
is I saw a cardboard
cutout of you backstage
and I was like,
"Oh, my God."
And like you were like
about to be singing as well,
so I was like you know,
"Start with the show,"
and everything,
it was crazy,
but it wasn't you.
- It's so funny 'cause that's happened
to a lot of people here,
because we have a cardboard cutout
they like do rehearsals with
and then I just do it like when I come,
and people have literally run in,
and been like, "Oh!"
And then it's like, nope.
Yeah, we just like to
fake people out here,
we just like to mess with y'all.
Well, we had a couple of
your Ted Lasso co-stars here,
they said that y'all got
to go to The White House,
we saw a picture,
was that so cool?
- It was crazy,
it was, yeah...
It was nice,
I mean, like the president
and the first lady were kind
enough to invite us over
to you know,
like talk about mental health with them
and you know,
like the aim was to you know,
destigmatize it
and it's an important-
- Which is so great 'cause
Ted Lasso does that.
- Yeah, it's an important
theme on our show
and so, yeah we got to go down
and speak to them,
and it was yeah,
it was crazy,
I think halfway through
I was pinching myself,
I was like,
"How the hell have I ended
up at The White House?"
- I'll tell you what,
I've been to The White House
and I heard,
I didn't even know they
had a bowling alley,
but apparently, they have a bowling alley
and you got to bowl there!
- They do, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] What in the world?
- It was dope, yeah.
- [Kelly] I'm not cool
enough to get that tour.
- Aw man, I mean listen,
we had to like slide-
- Did you get a strike in The White House?
- I didn't, Jason did,
Brendan did, Brett did,
I did not.
- Like, everyone did but you?
Wow, that's horrible.
- Thanks Kelly.
(Kelly laughing)
- That's horrible.
Have you ever been to The White House?
- No!
- Okay, so...
Okay, I've been there,
but I never bowled,
I was like,
"That's so cool."
- It's just such a shame,
we didn't get to bowl
with the president though,
that's the only thing,
'cause I'd have smoked him,
I was like...
That was my aim,
I was like,
as soon as they were like,
"Oh cool, like we get to
go to The White House."
- I don't know if you would've smoked him,
you were the one not doing strikes.
(crowd laughing)
So Toheeb, your momma's dream
was for you to be the UK's first
Black prime minister, right?
Have you let her down you feel, or?
- Disappointment 100%,
like 'cause that was
the route that I was on,
I was like a super academic kid in school
and then like just for some reason
just decided to U-turn into acting
and for her it must've been
insanely surprising though,
'cause it's like suddenly
your kid just might as well
have told you he wants to be a clown
and go to clown school
and yeah.
But you know,
I went to drama school
and once you know,
we started on our way with acting,
yeah she was insanely supportive.
So, my thing was always,
"I'm not gonna be the UK's
first Black prime minister,
but I might play him in a show one day."
- I know, that's...
I'm so curious,
like that's such a cool
thing to be active in
like as a kid,
like what do you think
made you pivot into acting?
- I mean, I had some really dope teachers,
but I don't know,
I think there's something about you know,
like being a kid with a funny accent,
I came from Nigeria
and there's something about performing
that is a way to you know,
you can hide in your characters I guess
and so, like that became a thing
where it was like,
I didn't feel so isolated
when I was a part of a company
or you know,
doing plays or hiding in a character
and so yeah,
that kinda just became
my escape in a little way
and then it became the
thing where I was like,
"If I'm doing law every day
for the rest of my life,
I'm gonna be pretty miserable,
but if I'm doing this thing,
then I might not be that sad."
So, yeah-
- Well, I can tell your
mom is super proud,
I'm a momma,
yeah, you're proud any time
your kid like finds themselves,
I said selves,
how many are in there?
Finds themself
and like really loves what they're doing,
and is passionate about it, that's cool.
- You're also making money.
- Yeah, there's that,
there's that.
You know, it's like I've moved out,
like, do you know what I mean?
I can afford to live by myself.
- [Kelly] Like, "Oh, we
can afford to do this."
- My brother
and I might be eating like bread,
and water every day, but-
- Oh my God,
I lived on ramen.
I lived on ramen,
that's all I ate.
- Yo, have you ever tried Indomie?
It's like Nigerian ramen noodles,
I'm gonna find a way to like grab you some
and get you some...
I mean, your probably don't eat-
- I love ramen,
yeah, I try everything.
I was very lucky,
so from 19 I ended up traveling
like all over the world,
so I've been to a lot of different places,
so I'll try anything,
I won't love everything,
but I'll try it.
- Let me know how you go,
I'm actually gonna, yeah.
That's my mission,
I'm gonna get you some Indomie.
- Okay, I like this mission.
I'm willing to do this.
- Do I get some?
- [Toheeb] That was a given.
- [Kelly] He's gonna bring
it to improv over there.
- [Toheeb] Everyone I meet gets Indomie.
- Perfect.
- So, I wanna ask about
your new show, The Power.
What can you tell us about it?
It looks kinda...
Like, why are you not allowed to be there?
They (indistinct) not like you there.
- Because I'm a man.
No, it's set in a world where women,
young women especially
generate this ability,
almost overnight to generate electricity
through their hands
and electrocute people at will-
- Cool power.
- [Toheeb] Yeah, insane.
- Yeah.
- And so, like overnight they become
the physically superior gender
and my character's a journalist,
and unknowingly breaks this story,
and you know,
like puts this video out on the internet
and suddenly, like amasses this you know,
following, and platform,
and becomes a bit of a spokesperson,
and a mouthpiece for this new thing.
And he goes on this
really interesting journey
of you know,
finding himself,
finding purpose
and figuring out what he wants to do
with his platform, you know?
Like, finding his own
power in the media almost
and yeah, it's a pretty amazing story,
like we have a lot of
brilliant characters,
an incredible cast
and yeah, I can't wait
to share it with people.
- I like the parallel too,
with like even women's
rights being taken away,
like of how they have
you know electricity,
then they're trying to take it, right?
I'm assuming-
- Oh 100%, yeah.
People aren't just gonna be like,
"Oh yeah, great.
Run the world."
- Yeah, yeah exactly, exactly.
- It would be really cool
though to be like, "Beep!"
Just for sometimes.
We need another...
This is why God didn't allow it.
We need another break,
Ted Lasso season three is on Apple TV+
and also check out The Power, everybody.
New episodes premiere every Friday,
exclusively on Prime Video.